vielen dank für die einführung viel ist
anlässlich des
den will
im jahr feiert über den begriff der
bildung geschrieben worden
zumal in zeiten wo mehr oder weniger
geglückte hochschulreformen ruf nach dem
nach ihm benannten bildungsideal laut
werden lassen immer wieder was jedoch
genau unter diesem bildungsideal zu
verstehen ist jenseits von
unspezifischer ganzheitlichkeit und der
so oft beschworenen einheit von
forschung und lehre bleibt indes häufig
unklar
ich werde in meinem vortrag dafür
argumentieren dass es gerade humboldts
begriff des geistes ist der weiteren
aufschluss über die oft unspezifische
und allgemeine rede von einheit ganzheit
bildungssprache geschichte und
schließlich menschheit gibt
meine these lautet dass geist bei
humboldt der einheit betrifft par
excellence ist jedoch kein abstrakter
soll ein konkreter begriff ist nichts
sofern er eine bestimmte form betrifft
die sich in verschiedenen bereichen
allen voran die sprache aber auch in der
geschichte der menschheit auf die
unterschiedliche art manifestiert und
zugleich als treibende kraft der
entwicklung und einheits bildung
fungiert das spezifische des geist
begriff humanitäre besteht gerade darin
phänomenen ihre spezifität zukommen zu
lassen
geis ist anders formuliert die bedingung
der möglichkeit von bedeutung und damit
wesentlich formal jedoch nicht frei
schwebend und vergeistigt sind immer
konkret und integre die bedeutung des
geistes nach umwelt besteht so marie
therese darin anderen bedeutung zu
verleihen
deswegen ist die bedeutung des geistes
eine bedeutung zweiter stufe ich komme
zum ersten punkt der wirt des geistes
der begriff des geistes liegt humboldts
schriften nicht etwa nur ausgesprochen
zugrunde sondern wurde von ihm selbst
zum gegenstand einer ausdrücklichen
reflexion gemacht in seiner 1797
erschienenen schrift über den geist der
menschheit die wie viele andere seiner
schriften fragment geblieben ist
sie umfasst in der werkausgabe nur 13
zeiten hat sich der 30-jährige humboldt
wie an keiner anderen stelle in seinem
umfangreichen werk mit dem begriff des
geistes befasst humboldts absicht steht
in diesem text darin eine zitat theorie
der bildung des menschen zu entwickeln
um den noch mal die tat mannigfaltigen
arten der tätigkeit welche der mensch zu
üben gelernt hat ihren wahren wert zu
bestimmen zu können wir in einem brief
an christian gottfried körner bereits
vier jahre zuvor geschrieben hat nichts
geringeres selbst wirklich vor als die
tat eine schrift über die letzte
bestimmung des menschen und den großen
stil im denken dichten und handeln zu
verfassen
humboldts begriff des geistes selbst in
besagtem fragmenten einer beobachtung an
die tiefen anthropologische einheit von
denken und handeln betrifft geht darin
um einen genuin menschliches bedürfnis
das darin besteht die tat in seinem
denken und handeln folge und einheit zu
beobachten der mensch zu humboldt tat
kann sich nicht begnügen bei der
beurteilung der gegenstände seine
tätigkeit und der wahl seiner mittel nur
bedingten rücksichten zu folgen
zum maßstab dessen was gut und wünschen
würde ist bloß dinge anzunehmen
die selbst in beziehung auf andere wert
haben muss vielmehr gilt nach humboldt
da hat er muss ein letztes ziel einen
absoluten maßstab aufsuchen und die
letzte muss eng und unmittelbar mit
seiner inneren natur verwandt sein
worin besteht der grund für diese
streben nach absolutheit und bin als der
einheit die humboldt ihr diagnostiziert
das mittelbare und bedingte kann nach
humboldt ii tat immer nur eine meinung
nur einseitig entweder unseren verstand
oder unsere empfindungen befriedigen nur
für das sind sie eigentlich und
innerstes wesen nahe berühren erwärmt
die unsere ganze und unsere gäste und
wahrhaft menschlichen natur
diese absolute maßstab der die einheit
von verstand und empfindung nationalität
und sinnlichkeit aufzeigt ist nach
humboldt der gepard inbegriff aller
wiesen oder wie gesagt die innere natur
mit menschen was versteht aber schon
bald genau unter dieser inneren natur
sie besteht allgemein darin dass der
mensch nach humboldt zitat den genuss
verstehen und das glück entbehren kann
in diesem aufschieben von wie man es
sagen könnte primär in trainieren wird
tendenzen von einer zweiten stufe es
steht also nach um gold der grund
inneren natur oder ein anderer
begrifflichkeit formuliert die
willensfreiheit des menschen derartige
koalitionen zweiter stufen die die
menschen in stand setzen sich von
unmittelbaren triebe und neigungen
distanzieren zu können
konstruiert oder bezeichnet wollte
konstituiert nach humboldt der begriff
der menschheit
dieser wiederum ist ich zitiere noch mal
nicht anderes als lebendige kraft des
geistes der sie basiert aus ihr spricht
sich wieder tätig und wirksam erweist
hier nun fällt zum ersten mal der
begriff des geistes der geist begriff
ist nach um gold in zweifacher hinsicht
ausgezeichnet
in suchen er 70 81 auf dem textblatt das
wesen der menschheit auf eine zugleich
allgemein und auch eigentümliche weise
als wesen und kraft selbst bedeutet und
darin bat zugleich auf ihre fachliche
und ungewöhnliche natur bezogen werden
kann sieht also hier schon ganz
rudimentär aufscheinen dass es dabei
tatsächlich um eine einheit begriff der
jedoch wie wir im folgenden sehen werden
konkret und nicht irgendwie büros
abstrakt humboldt schließt an dieser
recht allgemein gehaltenen bemerkung
einen längeren passes an den ich wegen
seiner bedeutung für den geist begriff
in seiner gänze vortragen möchte und er
aus dem textblatt unter vom 2 ganz
abgedruckt ist
humboldt führt darin gleich acht
merkmale an die ihm zufolge geist
charakterisieren
also zitaten noch 2
in beiden rücksichten nämlich wiesen
kraft ziemlich unsicher natur teamgeist
unter allen wörtern der man sich hätte
bedienen können das schädlichste erstens
man das ursprünglich von etwa findigen
den verstärken reif und getränken durch
die absonderung der defekten teile
weingeist hergenommen ist zweitens alles
streng genommen
es sei eher mit einem besonderen zusatz
dass reinholen sinnliche bezeichnet man
sagt richtiger seele und körper als
geist im körper und sehr häufig einer
geist drittens weil es gerade das
eigentümliche wort für dasjenige
umfängliche ist die melden wir gerade
noch genug körperliches einräumen um
erscheinen zu können
das synonym von gespendet die seeländer
verstorbenen wandeln als gespenster mehr
retten
weil es selbst in dieser bedeutung mehr
realität hat etwas kräftigeres und
stärkeres anzeigt als das sonst gleich
bedeutende gespenst so drückt es eine
tiefer liegende verwirrung aus wenn man
sagt er begeistert als er sieht
gespenster künftig psychologischen die
brauchen hier auf das bloß mechanisch
ist angewandt wird
das wort geist man sagt nie ein
geistreicher immer einen sinn reiser
mechaniker nie ein geistreicher immer
ein zahlreicher versuche geben so ist
auch spirituelle und verschieden 61
immer die ganze geschaffen hat einer
sache ihr wissen nicht eine einzelne
bestimmung andeutet und der henley von
dem leben gebraucht wird was durch eine
einzelne kraft äußerung hervorkommt
wenigstens insofern als man die zugleich
ausdruck
man sagt nie eine geistreiche immer eine
sinnreich erfindung selbst wenn das
erfundene wirklich geistreich wäre doch
liegt in diese einschränkung auf ein
paar etwas willkürliches siebten
geistreich und geistvoll immer nur da
gebraucht werden motive der rhein
intellektuellen kräfte mit lebendigkeit
der sinnlichen einbildungskraft
zusammenkommt sie am alten bezug
durchaus zu kant aber da kommen
genau darauf zu sprechen er spricht vfr
fort man sagt immer nur um eigentlich
ein geistvoller metaphysiker logiker das
wird auch uns wir versuchen wir sind nun
eigentlich machen wollt geistreich
achten
endlich war geil zugleich das
herrschende eigentümliche und echte
wiesn im gegensatz des buchstabens
anzeigen
es wird also eine ganze palette von
charakterisierung und möchte in folien
versuchen alle der wichtigsten einige
der wichtigsten punkte aus diesen
bestimmungen des geistes nach humboldt
mit eigenen worten mit anderen begriffen
zusammenzufassen erstens könnte man
sagen
geistiges ist mehr humboldt nichts
abstraktes sondern bezogen auf einen
energetischen pfund und damit konkret
und real wirksam
damit trifft humboldt implizit an die
alttestamentliche hebräische bedeutung
von rach an einem geist wird zunächst
etwas ungezähmtes und unverfügbare ja
beinahe wildes aber zugleich beleben
bist und ungeheuerlich inspirierendes
auftritt etwa dann mit der nada samson
im buch trichter dadurch in ekstase
versetzte
zitiere aus dem buch richter ist der 14
46 hat da kam der geist des herrn über
samson und samsung schriften löwen mit
bloßen händen als würde ein püppchen
verreisen oder wenn ihr buch samuel
berichtete zitat da kam gottes geist wo
archäologie über die boten fouls und sie
gebärdeten sich wie profis ein
verfügbarer unberechenbar geist der erst
im zuge des neuen testaments zum
heiligen geist vergeistigt und der
minister zitiert wird geist ist insofern
aus ängsten dem leben zusammenhängen
nicht mechanisches sondern organisch
strukturiert damit komme ich zu vom zwei
der zusammenfassung geist ist nach
humboldt ein einheits begriff deine
energie ware einheit von vernunft und
leben bedeutet drittens geist ist nicht
einfach fiel deutlich vielleicht hin
vieldeutig am weg sondern seine das wort
geist um seine vieldeutigkeit eindeutig
insofern es sich dabei um ein einheits
begriff handelt der gegensätzliches
synthetisch aufeinander betrieb damit
ist der geist begrifflich argumentieren
möchte ein begriff zweiter stufe geist
ist die bedingung der möglichkeit von
spezifischer bedeutung humboldt
untersucht nun verschiedene sprachen auf
ihre verwendung und prägung des geist
begriff europäischer tiere dem
italienischen ist die rettung nicht mehr
mehr mystisch als philosophisch im
französischen ist vom ursprünglichen
begriff der destination vorzüglich die
verfeinerung genommen
im englischen das belebende und feurige
des verstärkenden getränks welt
berichtet dagegen argumentiert um bolt
vor dem hintergrund seiner definition
der merkmale des geistes dafür dass
gerade in der deutschen sprache
die wichtigsten momente ihrer
spezifischen einheit bewarf gebiet sein
das zitat drei nämlich auch ganz vor
sagt zur vorkommnis zur verwendung des
begriffs im deutschen allein ist der
begriff der kraft des echten während
herrschend geblieben ganz muss kann ich
nämlich rühren alle diese wörter von den
begriff des baus des windes her
erst da davon und erst als mit afrikas
umfängliches sind sie auf das verfahren
der destination als nämlich das
ausziehen des weniger materiellen
übergegangen indes hat die
psychologische bedeutung wiederum bald
mehr bald weniger von dieser zeiten
metapher an sich gerissen
am meisten offenbar im französischen im
deutschen ist die anfängliche bedeutung
der herrschend geblieben und die zweite
metapher zeigt sich nur in einigen
redensarten wie ein geist aus einer
sache ziehen und so fort jetzt die
anfängliche bedeutung scheint sehr stark
gewesen sein und diese stärke hat mich
besser enthalten weil die wurzeln von
geist selbst deutsch
also durch ton und eigenständigkeit und
mehr ist dagegen spirit of history &
spirit von spiritus und die von pneu man
herkommt und wie das spiritus noch bei
den alten philosophisch gebraucht soweit
zur deutschen dem deutschen begriff des
gastes 100 argumentiert also implizit
dafür an die hebräische bedeutung von
hakan zukunft hier nochmal der
unsittliche gebrauch diese ausdrücke bei
den alten ist erst durch das christentum
entstanden und kommt aus dem hebräischen
her und vorzüglich sind die
psychologischen anwendung des worts
geist bei den neueren ihnen inhalten
fremd noch höher und authentischer als
den deutschen begriff geld vom gold
jedoch den griechischen begriff der dt
die tiere noch mal die ard ist deswegen
so humboldt ausgezeichnet da tat ist die
volle echte und eigentümliche kraft
anzeigt und ebenso gut von der innern
als äußeren bildung gebraucht wird es
ist besser als geist rt weil es nicht
wie jede metapher die missbrauch
unterworfen ist und weil es den begriff
rein aus der natur nicht aus unserer
ansicht der selten nimmt weil es ein
werk des beobachtens nicht der
einbildungskraft ist freilich erwartet
eben darum auch eine neue hause weniger
und verliert durch seine mehr
pragmatische kraft ein ideal i tät die
humboldt einschränken gemerkt bolt hatte
sich in seinem geist vorgenommen den
begriff geistes intra hinsichten zu
untersuchen nämlich ist die frage wohin
dieser geist besteht seitens wie er
erkannt wird und drittens wer gebildet
wird doch es ist zu dieser
systematischen ausarbeitung des geist
begriffs nicht mehr gekommen es handelt
sich um fragment ausgehend von diesen
acht in diesem quartal zwei gegeben
charakterisierung will ich im folgenden
kurz versuchen um wollte griff der
sprache der geschichte und der
menschheit auf diese art geistigen
merkmale hin transparent zu machen
komm zum punkt weil der geist der
sprache
in seiner im jahr 1836 fast 40 jahre
nach seinem geist fragment erschienene
schrift über die verschiedenheit des
menschlichen sprache aus und ihren
einfluss auf die geistige entwicklung
des menschengeschlechts hat tom wolters
verhältnis von geist und sprache
folgendermaßen bestimmt zitat vier
intellektualität und die sprache
gestatten und befördern
nur einander gegenseitig zu sagen die
formen die sprache ist gleichsam die
äußere äußerliche erscheinung des
geistes der völker ihre sprache ist ihr
geist und ihr geist ihre sprache man
kann sich beide nie identisch genug
denken objektivität und bedeutung von
sprache sind damit kein produkt der
bloßen konvention der villa deren
zuordnung von bedeutung sind eines
inneren prinzips oder einer geteilten
allen sprechern zugrundeliegenden form
sprachgemeinschaft und sprache befinden
sich nach humboldt als in einer intimen
wechselwirkung zieht hier nochmal wollt
fragt in dem ein volk der entwicklung
sprache als des werkzeuges jeder
menschlichen tätigkeit in ihm aus seinem
inneren freiheit erschafft sucht und
erreicht ist zugleich die sache selbst
als etwas anderes und höheres und dem
ist auf dem wege des fahrgeschäfts
schöpfung und grübelnde ahndung da
hingelangt wirkt es zu gleich wieder auf
die sprache zurück zum ball fast sprache
und sprechen als in einer wechselwirkung
begriffen also nicht einseitig dann ist
es wieder mal ein geschlossenes system
dass er im folgenden noch mit dem
metapher eines organismus in verbindung
bringen wird zugleich aber ist sprache
eben nichts statisches einmal
integrierbares schon wesentlich in bezug
auf das lebendige gespräch zu verstehen
als dynamischer prozessualer und
bedeutungs konzentrieren auf 6 die
humboldt betrug hier noch mal die
sprache in ihrem wirklichen lehrern
aufgefasst ist etwas gespendet und in
jedem augenblick vorübergehend es selbst
ihre erhaltung durch die schrift
fixierung ist immer nur eine
unvollständige monien artige
aufbewahrung die es doch erst wieder
bedarf
dass man dabei den lebendigen vortrag zu
versöhnlichen sucht die selbst ist kein
werk ergon sparen sondern eine tätigkeit
in ihre ware definition kann daher nur
eine genetisch sein und jetzt kommt ein
zentrales sie ist nämlich die sich
wiederholende arbeit des geistes den
artikulieren laut zum ausdruck des
gedanken feld zu machen humboldt fährt
an vierter stelle über den geist
möglichen einwänden vorgreifen ford
sieht hier noch mal die sprachen als
eine arbeit des geistes zu bezeichnen
ist schon darum ein vollkommen richtig
und adäquate ausdruck weil sie das datum
des geistes überhaupt nur in tätigkeit
und als solche denken lässt die zu ihrem
studium unentbehrliche zergliederung
ihres baus bildet uns sogar sie als ein
verfahren zu betrachten dass durch
bestimmte mittel zu bestimmten zwecken
vor schreitet und insofern wirklich als
bildung der nation antreten
arbeitest dessen zitat von humboldt ist
aber nicht individuell ist nicht rein so
etwas inter subjektives welches im
dynamischen austausch ergibt und als
solche ihre bedeutung konstruiert sagt
freundes dazu dass in dieser arbeit des
geistes artikulierten laut zum gedanken
ausdruck zu heben liegen die beständigen
gleichförmige so vollständig als möglich
und seinem zusammenhänge aufgefasst und
systematisch dargestellt macht die
formsprache sprache ist also könnte man
anders mit moderner begrifflichkeit
formulieren eine art geistige lebensform
man braucht nach wittgenstein zu denken
die ihre einheit durch die einheit der
nation als sprachgemeinschaft erhält und
damit in einer permanenten
wechselwirkung steht als solches die
sprache eine geistige operation ein
verfahren wie humboldt sagt sie ist die
tat dass bildende organ des gedankt
die intellektuelle tätigkeit durchaus
geistig durchaus üblich und
gewissermaßen spurlos vorüber gehend
wird durch den laut der rede äußerlich
und wahrnehmbar verdiene die straße sind
gar 1 und unzertrennlich voneinander
humboldt macht das wirken des geistes
auch am individuellen sprecher als
solchen fest wenn einer synthetischen
einheit von falschen bedeutung besteht
eine art geistigen rückkopplung oder
geschlossenen kreislauf in dem
subjektivität und objektivität der
sprache und bedeutung permanent
vermittelt sie nochmal die tätigkeit der
sinne muss ich mir der inneren handlung
des geistes synthetischer binden und aus
dieser verbindung reißt die vorstellung
los wird der subjektiven kraft gegenüber
zum objekt und kehrt als solches auf neu
wahrgenommen in jene zurück hierzu
arbeitet die sprache unentbehrlich dem
in ihr das geistige streben sich daran
durch die lippen bricht ziert das
erzeugnis beheben zum eigenen moritz
zurück die vorstellung wird also in die
wirklich objektivität hinüber versetzt
ohne darum der subjektivität entzogen zu
werden dieser markt nur die sprache und
ohne diese auch stillschweigen immer
vorgehende versetzung in dem tim hin zum
subjekt zurückkehren objektivität ist
die bildung des begriffs mithin alles
wahre denken unmöglich ohne daher sind
auf die mitteilungen zwischen menschen
und menschen zu sehen ist das sprechen
eine notwendige bedingung des denkens
einzeln in abgeschlossene einsamkeit
sprache ist nach humboldt also weder
endloses epi phänomen oder produkt von
konventionen sind eine sich in der
subjektiv und geschichtlich vollziehende
arbeit des geistes die zugleich als
belebend bildend und auch als einige
fundiert fungiert in seinem im jahr 1827
30 jahre nach dem geist fragment
gehaltenen wissenschaftlich vorteil über
den dual is also einem sprach ein
günstiges phänomen
sprachwissenschaftliche 10
hat humboldt die geistige struktur der
sprache weiter bestimmt und inter
subjektiv und dialogisch verortet und
hier kommt jetzt interessanter bezug zu
kants kritik der urteilskraft erscheint
er sagt nämlich in dem unsichtbaren
organismus des geistes den gesetzen des
denkens der klassifikation seine
kategorien aber wurzelt der begriff der
freiheit doch auf eine vierte und
ursprüngliche weise in dem satz und
gegensatz dem setzen und aufheben dem
fein und nichtsein dem ich und der welt
auch wo es die begriffe 3 und mehrfach
teilen entspringt der dritte weg aus
einem ursprünglichen geothermie oder
wird ihm denke gern auf die grundlage
einer solchen zurückgebracht der
ursprung und das dass er alles geteilt
und sein ist einheit deshalb ist nach
humboldt auch sprechen wie öffentlich in
der wechsel rede
verliert er fast in der frau unter
mehreren geräten die angebetete niemals
sich als einheit gegenüberstellt dem
hengst rollt weiter spricht sogar in
gedanken nur mit einem anderen oder mit
sich wie mit einem anderen und zieht
danach die kreise seiner geistigen
verwandtschaft sondern die wir reden
denn von den anders reden abgleich ist
damit als sprachliches phänomen wie ich
schon sagte wesentlich inter subjektiv
realisiert und das sieht humboldt auch
wie man noch etwas weiter aussehen
könnte am prozess des denkens auch das
denken ist nach humboldt in der
subjektiv erfasst man könnte auch sagen
die logisch
ich komme jetzt zum dritten punkt
nachdem ich die sprache untersucht hatte
auf ihre geistige struktur drei der
geistesgeschichte in seinen
betrachtungen über die bewegenden
ursachen der weltgeschichte die humboldt
im jahr 1808 treten also 20 jahre nach
seinem geist verfasst hat überträgt er
die form des geistes auf die geschichte
um gold hat die dort galt als ein
zusammenhang der als solcher nicht
unabhängig von denkenden entsprechenden
projekten existiert sind durch deren
beteiligung oder wie man auch sagen
könnte einklinken permanent
aufrechterhalten wird
die tiere noch mal denn auch was frucht
des geistes und der sinnes artist
wissenschaft kunst 70 einrichtung
verliert das geistige und wird zur
materie wir nicht weg heißt immer von
neuem beliebt alle diese dinge tragen
die natur des gedankens an sich denn nur
erhalten werden kann hingegen eher
gedacht wird alle das denken ist
individuelles sondern trägt vor
vernetzung dieser geschichtlichen
sprachliches zug vorbei die wenn man
sich nicht mehr einklinken diese
struktur zurückfällt wird sagen würde
es verliert das geistige wird zur
materie humboldt hat den tranken teilen
charakter des geistes besonders in
seinem vortrag über die aufgabe des
geschichts schreibens aus dem jahr 1821
weiter ausgeführt und dabei auch auf die
form des geistes soja der titel des
vortrags reflektiert hier nochmal zu den
wirken und schaffen kräften hat sich der
geschichtsschreiber zu werden hier
bleibt er auf seine eigentümliche gebiet
was er tun kann um zu der betrachtung
der labyrinthisch verschlungenen
begebenheiten der weltgeschichte in
deinem gemüter eingeprägt die form weg
zu bringen und der leyen ihr wahrer
zusammenhang erscheint ist diese form
von ihm selbst abzuziehen
der widerspruch darin zu liegen scheint
verschwindet bei näherer betrachtung
jedes begreifen eine sache selbst als
bedingung seiner möglichkeit hatte dann
zentral in den begreifenden schon ein
analogon das nachher wirklich begriffen
voraus eine vorgängige ursprüngliche
übereinstimmung zwischen dem subjekt und
objekt
und genau diese ursprüngliche
übereinstimmung in die geschichte in der
sprache könnte man als form des geistes
bezeichnet strukturelle identität
ich komme zum vierten punkt begeister
menschheit auch die der menschheit keine
struktur analogie zu humboldts sprach
begriff auf die form des geistes
zurückgeführt sagte dazu jede
menschliche individualität ist nach um
bolze parteien in der scheidung wurzeln
die idee dort einigen leuchtet die so
strahlend hervor dass sie die form des
individuums nur angenommen zu haben
scheint und mit ihr die täter offenbar
diese form der idee der menschheit 1
geiss besteht nach um gold in der
freiheit die sich sowohl in negativer
als auch positiver gestaltet wenn wir
noch mal wie man das menschliche wirken
entwickelt so bleibt die humboldt
schreibt nach abzug aller das leben
bestimmen den ursachen etwas
ursprünglich wenn ihr zurück dass
anstatt von ihren einflüssen erstickt zu
werden
sie merkt sie umgestaltet und dem selben
element liegt ein unaufhörlich tätiges
bestreben seine inneren eigentümlich
natur unseres daseins verschaffen
diese antwort iwe kraft des geistes
jemanden könnte als individuelles
allgemeines oder als allgemeines
individuelles manifestiert sich auch im
falle von nationen und geschichte wochen
oder fast
er sagt dazu folgendes mitten in dem
durch bedürfnis leidenschaft und
scheinbaren zufall geleiteten
begebenheiten der völker wirkt daher und
mächtiger als jene elemente das geistige
prinzip der individualität ford sucht
der ihm innewohnende ideen raum zu
verschaffen und es gelingt ihm wie zarte
pflanze durch das organische anschwellen
ihrer gefäße gemäuer springt das sonst
den einwirkungen von jahrtausenden
jahrhunderten trotzdem neben der
richtung welche völker und einzelne
menschengeschlecht durch ihre taten
erteilen lassen die formen geistiger
individualität zurück dauernder und
wirksamer als begebenheiten und ereignet
zwei kumpel wollte greift diese form
also nicht nur als dynamisch und
organisch sondern auch theologisch also
der geist hat nach humboldt
auch eine gewisse richtung wir werden
müssen dann auch schauen wirklich zu
häkeln verhält subjektiven objektiven
absoluten geist dann sagt jedenfalls so
viel zum der theologie von ziel das
gesicht sich hier nochmal der viele
geschichte kann nur die verwirklichung
der durch die menschheit darzustellen
idee sein
nach allen seiten hängen und in allen
gestalten in welchen sich die endliche
formen der idee zu verbinden vermag und
der lauf der gegebenheiten kann nur da
abbrechen wobei einander nicht mehr zu
durchdringen imstande sind
abschließend möchte ich als geist
begriff noch etwas problematisieren also
es scheint jedenfalls so zu sein dass
geist nach humboldt eingerichtet hat die
letztendlich zu einer moralischen
verfassung führt als einwohner gehen
prosperieren diese organische begriff
und jetzt könnte man durchaus kritisch
an humboldt einwenden
inwiefern die idee der menschheit und
die form des geistes wirklich auf das
moralische ideal ausgelegt sind
als beispiel möchte ich den begriff
bösen spiel bringen
es scheint nämlich dass auch im bösen
eine spezifische form von geistlichkeit
gelegen
und die ist schelling und guter zugs
punkt schelling sagt dazu die tiere
unvollkommenheit in allgemeinen
metaphysischen ist nicht der gewöhnliche
karte des bösen
da sich oft mit einer vortrefflichkeit
der einzelnen kräfte vereinigt zeigt die
vielfalt des gute begleitet also ich
denke man muss ein humboldt zurück
fragen ob wild die form des geistes
wirklich nur in einem fortschritt mündet
ein fortschritt initiiert oder ob es
nicht formen von geistigkeit gibt die
gerade auch böse genannt werden können
sozusagen sich individualität besonders
profiliert das wäre meine frage wider